welcome to screen crush i'm your host
derek voss and what the hell is going on
with the ending of moonlight episode
four it's one of the biggest mind books
we've had in the mcu since one division
and there's so much going on with it
that we need to break down the episode
takes a turn at breakneck speed like
gwen stacy and after mark is apparently
shot we dive into a movie called toon
buster before joining him on a
psychiatric ward similar to 12 monkeys
in case you haven't seen it that movie
stars bruce willis as a time traveler
who goes back to stop a killer virus
from being unleashed unfortunately he
travels back way too far and due to his
crazy stories about the feature he sent
to an insane asylum try the first act of
the movie you're very much questioning
whether the time travel storyline is
actually real or if it's just the
hallucinations of a madman that's
definitely the vibe i get from this
episode's twist and the entire situation
actually pulls directly from the comics
in almost every episode breakdown we've
talked about something from the seminal
jeff lemiron which featured mark in a
psychiatric hospital along with his
other side characters such as crawley
who makes an appearance as a bingo
caller now you probably want to know
what happens in the book in order to
understand what's going on here so for
the first part of the video i'm just
going to dive right into it i know my
breakdowns that i typically tend to go
in chronological order but this ending
is so off the wall that even michael
jackson would say it's bad to make you
wait until the break of dawn for it
sorry those are the only michael jackson
songs that worked in that sentence and
if you don't want things possibly ruined
then i will leave timecodes below so you
can skip ahead to just where we talk
about the episode however there are a
couple of big changes that they do in
the show that mean they probably aren't
following things exactly as how they are
on the page anyway in the comics mark is
holed up in an asylum which is overseen
by a doctor named dr emmett who is
actually revealed to be omit her
orderlies are called billy and bobby
which just so happens to be the name of
the two police that we met in episode 2.
these two were also revealed to be
jackals which could have been referenced
in the two jackals that have popped up
in the series now omi kept trying to
convince mark that his entire life as
moon knight was just a fantasy and that
he'd been there since he was 12 years
old however visions of konchu came to
him and told him that he had to remember
who he was in order to piece together
his fractured psyche donning a
pillowcase as a mask in his [ __ ] as a
costume he fought his way out of the
asylum which was in fact revealed to be
an illusion located in a reality outside
of time and space known as the other
void he'd been held prisoner there but
mark managed to escape his personalities
then jumped through several realities
that all kind of played with our
expectations stephen grant was a tv show
producer that thought he was working on
a series called moonite this show also
featured midnight man on it and it would
switch completely when he became jake
jake was a cab driver who was suspected
of murder and there was also the
moonlight personality this was a sci-fi
story featuring an astronaut called
moonite and we watched as he jumped
between all of these whilst getting to
the bottom of who was behind it all in
the end it was revealed that konchi was
the one who'd orchestrated the entire
thing and that he'd done this so that he
could fracture mark's mind and take over
his body we discover that he'd been
watching him since he was a kid and
mark's personalities all came together
to crush his skull once and for all i
think the series will differ from this
quite a lot as conscious trapped in
stone whilst all this is going on and we
have tarouette popping up at the end she
never appeared in any of the issues and
the book was very much just about
escaping the other void in this series i
think we'll have mark get out of it but
then he has to go stop harrow so
according to us finding out that kunchu
constructed all of this thanks i'm here
all week instead next time i think we'll
likely follow mark as he delves into his
psyche and here we'll encounter
flashbacks to when he got his powers and
we'll also finally meet his parents we
know both have been cast so yeah that's
where i can see things going kunchu also
said to steven
when the gods imprison me tell mark to
free me
so yeah i can't see that being a task
mark has to do in order to get his suit
back the reason he doesn't wear it
throughout this episode at any point is
because it's very much linked to konju
and if he's not there then mark can't
become moon knight now the entry picks
up immediately after the events of last
week which saw stephen and conscie
rolling back the night sky to the day
that omit was imprisoned the avatars of
the god have trapped him and he's placed
amongst nine others this is in the great
pyramid of giza which we were told had
nothing inside of it in the first
episode it looks like someone was stuck
the great pyramid of geezer for a
rubbish dump it's not like there's
anything in there however this was wrong
kids are stupid and it might have even
belonged to an avatar of ahmed who we
learned in the comics was a pharaoh at
one point this is sort of changed up in
the episode so we get them to be
alexander the great but yeah there is a
lot of things going on that i'd love to
hear your theories on there are 10
guards who are trapped in stone with
potentially taroup being one of them as
her avatar didn't appear at the meeting
last week there has been a lot of back
and forth over how many gods there are
with steven originally saying there were
nine but that the museum poster got it
wrong and that they lost two what i'm
trying to point out i'm not trying to
slag off marketing but there's been a
major blunder because they've got seven
gods here and the indiana has nine this
potentially is ahmed and konchu who we
know are outcasts however the other nine
being locked up here either means one of
two things the first one being that
there's more gods we don't know about or
that the avatars have locked up all like
gods kind of leaning more towards the
former but let me know below if you
think something's different because yeah
one of those things i'm not really sure
on now we could do the title sequence
which now has dramatic music over the
top of it
this is completely different to the pop
songs and fanfare that we've had in
other episodes now i really love how the
series is somewhat something that you
can divide up into three parts due to
its six episode length the first two
episodes were set in london three and
four set in egypt and it looks like five
and six might be set in the other void
or mark's mind they also carry certain
aesthetics to them too with the first
two entries being a lot like momento and
also fight club three and four are like
indiana jones and the mummy and five in
six
who knows now from here we see a scarab
in the desert climbing up a dune scarabs
are very important as as of course the
golden scarab and in episode three we
learned that layla's father nicknamed
her his little scarab i wonder what your
father would think of his little scarab
now
you think his dig sites were any place
for a child
we discovered more about him in this
episode and learned that he used to wear
a cloth that covered his face which had
them all over it showing how much he
loved his daughter and her nickname now
it's not too long before harrow's men
arrive at the scene and with steven
being out of it she has to take them
down get a lot of action scenes with her
in this episode and it's nice that you
get some character development too one
of the best parts of the mummy was evie
played by rachel wise i get a lot of
vibes of her here in the layla character
throughout the episode she's constantly
being resourceful and there's more
flares in it than a 70s disco not only
does she throw it in the bullets to blow
up the truck but she later drops it
against the mummy in order to kill it
honestly when i was watching this
episode i didn't really make that many
notes for stuff about the first half
hour because it was pretty
straightforward there's not that many
easter eggs but we do continue the mark
steven costume design of having him
wearing something all white with a hood
this is of course riffing on the
moonlight costume and it's a really nice
touch we also get a great exchange with
steve and mark and the jeep as the
former refuses to hand over the body we
learn that mark very much abandon layla
and actually get a lot of the backstory
for this filled in throughout the entry
now we learned that layla's father was
amongst the dead archaeologists that
were brought up in episode 2 by bobby
and billy they were taken out by a
mercenary who we learn was a partner of
mark this pulls directly from the comics
and in the source material mark blew out
to a dig site that had an earth
conscious temple with his partner al
bushman upon arriving at the dig bushman
realized how rich he could get by
selling the buried treasure and he
killed all the archaeologists there mark
tried to stop him and bushman beat the
crap out of him before he fled with the
gold mark was at death's door but he was
found by the locals there that all
worshiped konchu they took him before
the shrine of the god and the pair made
a deal together in exchange for healing
him and bringing him back from the brink
mark would become conscious avatar and
the rest is history now we do get a shot
in the new tv spot that looks like this
moment in which marcus resurrected and
given the suit there's also the
possibility that we will see bushmen at
some point and though a season two of
the show hasn't been announced i can't
imagine him showing up in a post-credits
scene or something bushman is a major
moonlight villain and there are heavy
hints towards him throughout this entry
he of course murder leila's father so it
makes sense that the next big arc would
feature him now interestingly in the
comics layla or rather marlene was at
the dig site when her dad was killed
however they completely removed that
plot element here i think it's because
it adds some dramatic tension with mark
keeping a secret from layla about the
worst thing that's ever happened to her
now as they move through the caverns
they come across me and also see a dig
site led by harrow it's completely
abandoned and we get another great
exchange with mark and steven in the
reflection of a table there's kind of
some debate over whether steven has
mark's abilities too and some nice
sexual tension between stephen and leila
does it count as cheating i don't know
but stevie boy sticks to some bro code
and tells leila that mork is trying to
keep her safe because khan she
threatened to take her as his avatar
eventually the pair kiss and mark takes
over to punch steven in the face which
will smith should have done to himself
by laughing at that gi jin joke have we
completely milked that topic until the
point it's not even funny anymore yup
and that's why my views and likes have
been down this month yay heavy spoilers
fell off good riddance see you chump
now as they make their way through the
tubes we get some classic exploration
scenes that feel like they were ripped
out of indiana jones tomb raider and
uncharted they find bullets on the
ground which teased towards the
pharaoh's servants that sharp later on
upon walking around it enough times
steven realizes that the entire
structure is actually based on the eye
of horus
this
whole structure
it's a symbol now the eye of horus is
something that pops up in a lot of
egyptian mythology and typically it
represents well-being healing and
protection it was believed that horus
and seth bought each other to become the
rulers of the gods after osiris perished
set apparently gouged out horus eyes and
the latter attempted to use it to bring
his dad osiris back from the dead
tracing the tongue of the eye they make
their way to the avatar who we learn is
alexander the great alexander the great
is viewed as one of the greatest
military minds in history and he ended
up building an empire that spanned from
macedonia to egypt and from greece to
india this quotes about him saying that
when he saw the breadth of his kingdom
that he wept because there was nowhere
else to conquer and him being an avatar
makes a lot of sense he'd pretty much be
invincible and i love when they tie
comic book lore in with real history now
we also find out how amit is bound this
could tie into how they free konshu and
just in the same way that they unleash
amit they might do the same eventually
their journey is interrupted by one of
the pharaoh's servants carrying out a
mummification on one of harrow's men
difficult to make out who this is but it
could be fitzgerald oh yeah like i said
difficult to really tell and i don't
want anyone mentioning the comments
otherwise i'm kicking the off now the
servants are creepy as hell and they
have some terrifying clicks that they
use to see what's going on in their
environment this is known as
echolocation and it's seen in bats who
rely on sound to make their way in the
dark doors are used by the clickers and
the last of us i'm getting a lot of
vibes of that here as layla ducks and
hides whilst it clicks above her head
blind they rely on noise to track their
prey and there's lots of horror vibes as
it stalks layla through the area who is
down on her knees now this somewhat
pulls from the jeff lemire run and after
mark escaped the asylum he ended up
being chased by mummies in the next part
the other void after she jabs a flare on
its head she sends it flying over the
edge and it's a great scene with lots of
terrifying imagery now inside the tomb
mark finds several artifacts top ones
two
therefore t e
macedonian no what
no way that's not right that can't be
right that's macedonian the macedonian
text of course is our first clue it's
alexander the great and elsewhere leila
and harrow come face to face harrow
talks about her father and he brings up
his nickname for her
my little scare
turns out he theorized that egyptian
gods lived amongst them and harold of
mark's pass through the scales showing
him elements of it in episode one steven
reaches out to alexander's throat as he
was known as the voice and it all comes
to a head when layla reunites with him
mark finally takes control after she
confronts him over her father's death
and as we explained before going off the
comics he's telling the truth about what
happened with him turns out he went to
leila to tell her but they just ended up
banging instead which nice moves really
good of your mark anyway harrow's men
arrive and mark grabs the pharaoh's axe
which looks very similar the one that he
used as a grappling hook in the comics
he puts up a good fight but harrow
shoots him and without the armor he
seemingly dies now it's at this point
that things get wilder than a downing
street potty as he descends into another
realm potentially located in his own
mind or the other void firstly though we
get the film tomb buster starring
stephen grant a suave swashbuckling
explorer who raids a tomb the tombstone
logo is very similar to indiana jones
and the name of course is playing on
tomb raider there's lots of things going
on with this moment firstly this is a
film in which stephen grant is a
character the jeff lemiron had stephen
as someone who was involved in tv and
everything from his perspective played
out like a show rather than what was
really happening mark spector also
produced a series of his life in the
2011 moonlight run which this could be
riffing on beyond that though what we
see might have been real and mark could
have grown up watching this as a kid
when his d.i.d began he may have ended
up inventing steven as a persona based
on this which would tie into his
obsessions over archaeology they also
have a lovely cockney accent
maybe so
you've got pluck
now let's see what we can find on our
friend here now in addition to this last
week had what looked like a green screen
in it i actually got sent the four
episodes early and when i watched that
although it was just unfinished vfx but
now knowing what we know i think it
works really well to add to the theory
that it might have been a tv set well so
yeah before you start yeah every time i
say i got the episodes early someone
kicks off saying i'm just lying about my
theories but i tell you what punk i
watch these episodes one by one week by
week after they released so i could do
theories on them yeah i didn't watch
them all in advance took my time with
them and milked them for as many
theories as i could disney air mickey
you know mickey he knows what i've
watched and what i've accessed and do
you not think he'd be sending the goons
around if i was breaking embargo every
week and just throwing spoilers out
willy-nilly do you not think that do not
listen man just shut the f just shut up
anyway we're yet to find out what
triggered marks the id but in the comics
his mother died when he was very young
and i believe that next week we'll watch
this play out as we explore his psyche
more from here we pull out to see
crawley calling bingo numbers and in the
comics he too joined mark in the asylum
nice to see him out of his living statue
costume and he's way more in line with
what we typically see in the source
material now crawley calls out the
number b22 which we've spent the last
couple of days scrambling behind the
scenes to try to find a meaning for
marvel posted this on their twitter as
well so it does seem like it has some
significance though we can't figure out
exactly what it is however we have our
theories and potentially it's linked to
moon knight volume 122 which had a
really famous cover of all the
personalities and mirrors this mirror
has somewhat been referenced in the
series so far and the issue had a major
appearance by jake lockley now we spoke
to ryanairy yes we are friends behind
the scenes and he said that he thinks it
has a meaning because the bingo card
itself doesn't have any letters or the
number 22 on it therefore it could be
showing that the entire situation is
fake because the number being called out
it doesn't exist definitely go check out
his breakdown right after this where i'm
sure he'll talk about it more and one of
you guys probably know the answer so if
you've figured it out then drop it below
now beyond this we have a man playing
with a rubik's cube and mark also did
this in episode one the orderlies are
bobby and billy much like in the comics
and donna sits there with a cuddly
scarab from the gift shop that was too
seen in the first century there's also a
woman that draws a picture of a bird
with conchus head and though i thought
this might be the passport maker from
episode 3 i don't think it is cupcakes
are pushed about on a trolley and this
of course calls back to the chase in
episode 1. lastly we heard to mark who
sat beside a goldfish and there's also
some photos of the images from his
postcards stuck up on the whiteboard
lana comes forward and says that mark
won bingo and after he fails to get a
response from the mirror he falls out of
his wheelchair he drops a moonlight
figure that looks like a handmade
legends one that you'll probably be
getting for christmas because everyone
is about to be broke as [ __ ] yay the 20s
have been great yay now it's theory time
theory time theory time theory time so
in these scenes we might get the
potential confirmation that layla will
end up becoming the scarlet scarab in
the comics he was called abdul fowl and
laila's full name is laila abdullah
al-fali which might be a nod to that
might be a reach though but it might be
a nod layla's nickname was of course a
little scarab and if you look at her in
these scenes she also has a bimbal on
her little finger this has a red scarab
on it so yeah scarlet scarab confirmed
and that's the end of theory time
now mark is also strapped to the chair
like how he's strapped at the bed in the
comics and he's taken before harrow as
you mentioned in the source material dr
emmett was amit but with harrow being
its avatar it makes sense that they
change it up now he also drops a quote
by carl jung
no tree can ascend to the light of
heaven if it doesn't descend to the
depths of hell this very much summarizes
what mark himself is going through as
he's descended into whatever this is
there's also images of germany harrow's
table is the one hr used in episode 2.
there's his sandals which we catch in
the mirror the walls are white almost
like the texture of the moonlight
costume and he also brings up steven
you know steven
of course
i know steven now finally mark breaks
and he remembers what happened
[Music]
mark escapes the room and he runs
through the white hallways which begin
to twist and alter around him almost
like the dreams in inception when
someone realizes they're in one from
this point he runs into a room and here
he finds steven now the fact that
they're together shows us very much in
mark's mine and the pair will likely
join together beyond this we also get a
hint of egg luckily as there's another
sarcophagus that they don't open in case
you're unaware in the comics mark
actually has three personalities and
these are himself stephen and also jake
so far jake has been absent in the show
but there have been several clues
towards him firstly i don't think mark
would have organized to date with
another woman if he was still married to
layla mark also clearly tried to buy one
thing goldfish so that steven wouldn't
be suspicious the next day he's clearly
trying to hide that he exists whereas
jake is going out and about organizing
dates at steak houses and so on and so
forth there was also the bit in episode
3 where someone had been going on a
killing spree and neither marcus stephen
would admit to doing it beyond this
there was the accent changer potentially
showing that jake was there i'm looking
for sentry sarcophagus
hello what
are you doing here you shouldn't be here
watching what this joker just puts on no
more mock games in his backyard for fun
looking for centuries sarcophagus
what are you doing here you should be
here watching what this joker just puts
on normal mock games in his backyard for
fun a huge shout out to youtube user
random character for also saying that
they think jake is the only one who can
take over the body without permission
absolutely love that theory and it makes
sense with the blackout from episode 3.
now the episode ends with them coming
across the goddess of fertility tarouite
who was given an odd two in episode one
when donna asked steven to hand the
hippo plushies over to her
bring those hippos up here will you yeah
sure
car wet it
the hippo got his towel
it's a great way to end the episode and
it just leaves everyone like what the
hell is going on
hi
[Applause]
so going forward i think that she will
perhaps make them her avatar so that
they can escape and they might even team
up with jake i do feel like the next
episode will answer a lot of questions
about mark's past and it'll sort of
explain his origin story and we might
even get a hint at buschmann we could
also have the blanks filled in such as
what happened in the cupcake scene and
the missing day that steven had lots of
things i can do with it i feel like this
show is getting better every single week
there's not really been any lower points
and i think that each entry improves on
the last actually read a twitter thread
the other week that went through what
makes you a good reviewer and they said
that you have to include the negatives
too but i must be absolutely crap
because i don't really have any
criticisms the show is easily my
favorite mcu one so far and though i
feel like each one of them has their
strong points this one has been
consistently great throughout all in all
another banger of an episode and i'd of
course love to hear your thoughts so
make sure you comment below and let me
know we're also running a competition
right now which will be called on the
15th of may all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now say
that to you then message me on twitter
at heavyspoilers you want someone else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the batman which will
be linked on screen right now had a
right good laugh with it one of our best
videos if i say so myself so yeah go
head over there right after this
otherwise i'm kicking off yet but not
really because i love you you take care
of yourself enjoy the rest of your week
i hope to see you in the next one take
care peace